france un énarque on remplace un autre à
la présidence de la compagnie nationale
pour être plus précis le sortant jacques
friedmann est un ami personnel de
jacques chirac
celui qui sera nommé le 5 octobre
prochain jacques attali est le frère
jumeau du conseiller spécial du
président de la république qui
d'ailleurs certaines pages acm et berna
et la polémique rebondit sur la vase ce
supposé des présidents à la tête des
grandes sociétés nationalisées voici le
commentaire de maryse mano
officiellement jacques friedmann est
tombé à cause de l'accident de l'airbus
a320 à mulhouse
tout comme philippe rouvillois de la
sncf a chuté sur les accidents
meurtriers des gares de lyon et de l'est
en fait tous les deux sont les victimes
du système des dépouilles
particulièrement en vogue depuis
l'alternance
bernard attali lui même en avait fait
les frais après l'arrivée de jacques
chirac à matignon il avait dû quitter la
compagnie d'assurances le gan qui ne
dirigeait que depuis moins de deux ans
gauche et droite ont ainsi adopté la
même attitude logique politiquement il
logique économiquement vis-à-vis des pdg
des entreprises publiques rappelez-vous
1982 et 1986 et plus récemment
l'éviction des patron de l'uap et et du
crédit lyonnais
seule différence aujourd'hui beaucoup de
sociétés nationalisées ont été
privatisées impossible de changer leur
tête
il faut agir sur les noyaux durs des
actionnaires une tâche beaucoup plus
difficile
en tout cas avec le départ de jacques
friedmann le ministre des transports a
désormais les mains libres pour pousser
air france a racheté les parts de la
compagnie ut adam air inter et à devenir
petit à petit propriétaire d'air inter